L'ordre du jour appelle
les questions au gouvernement.
La première d'entre elles va être
posée par monsieur Frédéric Petit
pour le groupe Démocrate.
- Frédéric Petit: Merci.
Monsieur le ministre des Armées,
les Ukrainiens souffrent pour
leur liberté et pour la nôtre.
Je le disais ici le 24 février
2022, la guerre d'Ukraine, c'est
la confrontation de deux modèles.
Sur ces terres européennes qui
nous ont vus nous déchirer pendant
des siècles, des migrations, des
chocs culturels, quel modèle va
faire l'unité?
L'impérialisme,
la loi du plus fort?
Pour nous,
démocrates européens,
c'est unis dans la diversité et
dans nos différences que nous
pourrons affronter le 21e siècle.
Pour nous, les relations
économiques, ce sont les fonds de
convergence de solidarité, et non
pas le chantage au gaz.
La diversité des langues est aussi
indispensable à l'humanisme et à
la démocratie que la biodiversité
à la planète.
La mobilité, c'est Erasmus, pas le
nettoyage ethnique.
Pour nous, la démocratie exige
qu'on la défende lorsqu'elle est
agressée.
L'Ukraine fait partie de la
famille des démocraties
européennes.
Aujourd'hui, la situation
militaire semble stable et la
fatigue supposée des Ukrainiens
n'est qu'une des multiples
narrations de la guerre de
désinformation russe qui fait
rage.
Cette guerre, nous devons
l'emporter avec ou sans les
Etats-Unis, car elle est avant
tout la nôtre, et nous serons de
plus en plus seuls en face de
notre destin et celui des enfants
de nos petits-enfants.
C'est bien la patrie de nos
patries qui est en danger.
Monsieur le ministre, à l'heure où
nos livraisons marquent le pas,
comment notre pays se prépare-t-il
à affronter ce défi de la défense
de nos démocraties?
Quelle échéance à trois semaines,
à trois mois, à trois ans?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Patricia Mirallès,
ministre en charge des anciens
combattants.
- Patricia Mirallès: Je vous prie
d'excuser le ministre des Armées,
qui est actuellement en
déplacement.
Depuis le début de la guerre, la
France s'est engagée à soutenir
l'Ukraine dans sa légitime défense
contre l'agression de la Russie.
Ce soutien militaire répond aux
mêmes critères définis par le
président de la République: une
aide utile, une aide qui ne
conduise pas à l'escalade et une
aide qui n'affaiblisse pas la
défense de la France.
Une des spécificités de notre
soutien est que nous fournissons
des capacités complètes:
équipements, formation,
maintenance.
Je rappelle le rapport des
députés: ce soutien doit
s'inscrire dans la durée.
Vous soulignez que nous ne pouvons
indéfiniment puiser dans les
stocks de nos forces armées.
C'est ce qu'a initié le ministre
des Armées à Kiev en septembre
dernier.
Nous passons d'une logique de
session à une logique de
partenariat industriel entre
l'Ukraine et nos entreprises.
Vous avez voté dans la loi de
finances de fin de gestion
l'amendement du fonds spécial pour
l'Ukraine, qui permet de lui
fournir les armements à hauteur de
200 millions.
Nous nous coordonnons avec nos
partenaires pour structurer l'aide
à l'Ukraine.
La France apporte une contribution
majeure en prenant la tête d'une
coalition capacitaire dans le
domaine de l'artillerie.
La France continue d'apporter un
soutien à l'Ukraine par les
formations.
1000 militaires ukrainiens en 2023
ont été formés par nos soins.
Ces formations ont vocation à se
poursuivre en 2024 et à s'étendre
à d'autres domaines.
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci, madame
la ministre.
La parole est à monsieur Pierre
Morel-A-L'Huissier pour le groupe
LIOT.
- Pierre Morel-A-L'Huissier: Ma
question s'adresse à la ministre
des Solidarités.
Comme vous le savez, la
proposition de loi Bien vieillir a
été adoptée en première lecture le
23 novembre dernier à l'Assemblée.
Malgré une intention très
ambitieuse, le texte ne
s'accompagne pas de financement.
Au-delà de quelques dispositions
visant à garantir les droits des
personnes âgées, à lutter contre
la maltraitance en EHPAD, ce texte
n'est pas une réponse suffisante
aux enjeux du vieillissement et de
la perte d'autonomie d'une partie
de la population.
Le 17 novembre, vous avez admis,
dans le cadre de la présentation
d'une feuille de route, le
principe d'une loi de
programmation grand âge qui
devrait être présentée d'ici
prochain.
Celle-ci devrait présenter une
prise en charge par l'Etat de la
moitié des nouvelles politiques
d'autonomie dès 2025, un protocole
pluriannuel pour le recrutement
des 50.000 postes en EHPAD pour
2030, et une cartographie des
besoins des EHPAD.
Pourriez-vous nous assurer que les
financements nécessaires pour les
besoins des personnes en situation
d'autonomie et de dépendance
résidant en structure sociale,
médico-sociale ou nécessitant des
soins à domicile?
La reconnaissance des
accompagnants sera-t-elle incluse
dans le cadre du futur texte?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Aurore
Bergé, ministre des Solidarités.
- Aurore Bergé: Merci.
Monsieur le député, merci de
saluer le vote qui a été très
large dans le cadre de la
proposition de loi.
Votre groupe y a pris toute sa
part et je vous en remercie à
nouveau.
Nous avons présenté une stratégie
interministérielle.
De nombreux membres du
gouvernement étaient présents.
C'est bien toute notre société qui
doit s'adapter à ce défi majeur et
heureux de notre société, qui est
que nous avons une espérance de
vie en bonne santé qui progresse.
Pour beaucoup de Français, c'est
devenu une source d'angoisse, sur
comment vont-ils faire face à ce
vieillissement et comment
feront-ils face au vieillissement
de leurs parents?
Nous avons besoin d'une loi de
programmation pour y répondre.
C'est l'engagement que la Première
ministre a pris en fixant un
calendrier, et je dois présenter
cette loi à l'été prochain pour
qu'elle puisse être définitivement
adoptée à la fin de l'année 2024.
Cette loi doit répondre à
plusieurs grandes questions.
Face aux nouveaux besoins dans
notre société, quels sont les
leviers d'offres que nous devons
construire pour sortir de cette
logique du tout EHPAD?
Quels sont les leviers de
financement que nous devons
réussir à déterminer ensemble dans
le cadre de cette trajectoire?
Comment avoir les compétences
nécessaires en termes de
professionnels qualifiés?
Ce sont les questions auxquelles
ce projet de loi doit pouvoir
répondre.
Les besoins nouveaux, les offres
nouvelles, les besoins de
financement et la trajectoire que
nous nous fixons.
C'est un défi essentiel à relever.
En 2030, un Français sur trois
aura plus de 60 ans.
Dès janvier prochain, je lancerai
une coconstruction avec les
parlementaires et je solliciterai
l'ensemble des groupes
parlementaires pour avoir une
vraie coconstruction de cette loi.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
Monsieur le député?
- Pierre Morel-A-L'Huissier:
J'entends bien l'orientation.
Je vous le redis, il y a une
souffrance dans les EHPAD, une
vraie difficulté au niveau des
aides-soignants.
Il faut que ça aille très vite
parce que depuis qu'on dit qu'il y
aura une loi, il est temps de
mettre les choses en place.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Frédérique
Meunier pour le groupe Les
Républicains.
- Frédérique Meunier: Merci.
Madame la ministre, de nombreux
établissements de santé subissent
de plein fouet la réalité de la
politique gouvernementale de
transfert du paiement de vos choix
politiques vers nos établissements
médicaux et hospitaliers.
Rien que dans mon département, la
Corrèze, des motions sur la
situation budgétaire des EHPAD et
des centres hospitaliers sont
votées, demandant à l'Etat de
prendre ses responsabilités.
Ces établissements font face à des
situations budgétaires inédites.
Après la forte inflation de 2021,
notamment pour les dépenses
alimentaires et énergétiques,
après les difficultés de
recrutement, avec une pénurie de
médecins et d'aides-soignants,
votre politique est insensée.
Quand l'Etat décide des mesures
salariales nécessaires, quand
l'Etat décide des mesures de
soutien au pouvoir d'achat des
agents de la fonction publique,
quand l'Etat décide les
revalorisations salariales du
travail de nuit, des gardes du
dimanche, des jours fériés, mais
quand l'Etat oublie de compenser
financièrement cette augmentation
de charges sociales nouvelles
qu'il a imposées, les laissant à
la charge seule de ces
établissements médicaux, c'est
irraisonnable.
Ces dispositions gouvernementales
menacent la santé financière de
nos établissements, certains étant
même dans l'obligation d'ouvrir
une ligne de trésorerie pour
éviter le défaut de paiement.
Madame la ministre, allez-vous
prendre en compte l'urgence de la
situation financière inquiétante
et dégager des crédits pour les
établissements en grande
difficulté?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie, la parole est à madame
Aurore Bergé, ministre des
Solidarités.
- Aurore Bergé: Merci, madame la
députée.
Est-ce qu'il y a urgence?
La réponse est évidemment oui.
Comment est-ce que nous agissons?
Il était temps de ne plus avoir de
barrière entre le sanitaire et le
médico-social, car cela a généré
beaucoup de frustration entre deux
secteurs qui doivent travailler
ensemble.
C'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
annoncé que lorsqu'il y aurait des
revalorisations dans le secteur,
cela devait être la même chose
dans le secteur de l'hôpital.
C'est à la charge des
départements, notamment sur la
question des EHPAD.
Dès 2024, nous allons augmenter le
soutien aux départements et aux
conseils départementaux de 150
millions d'euros.
Plus aucun département dans notre
pays ne sera compensé à moins de
40% de ses dépenses en matière
d'appât.
L'année prochaine, je réunirai les
conseillers départementaux autour
d'une feuille de route qui va être
discutée.
A partir de 2025, 50% de toutes
les dépenses nouvelles des
départements en matière
d'autonomie seront compensées par
l'Etat, ce qui serait absolument
inédit comme soutien de la part de
l'Etat aux départements.
Il y a des situations d'urgence
dans un certain nombre
d'établissements.
En 2023, ça s'est traduit par près
de 700 millions d'euros que nous
avons débloqués pour aider et
accompagner plus de 7000
établissements médico-sociaux au
service d'aides à domicile.
Encore, c'est plus de 5 millions
d'euros.
Nous allons avancer sur le soutien
pour avoir une vraie trajectoire
pluriannuelle.
- Frédérique Meunier: J'ai bien
entendu ce que vous avez dit.
Il faut compenser les charges qui
ne cessent d'augmenter.
Il n'y a pas d'amour sans preuve
d'amour.
Je sais que vous nous aimez.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Marie-Agnès
Poussier-Winsback pour le groupe
Horizons.
- Marie-Agnès Poussier-Winsback:
Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de la Transformation
et de la Fonction publiques.
Pendant plus d'une vingtaine
d'années, les différents
gouvernements de gauche et de
droite se sont trompés.
Ils se sont trompés en imaginant
que la dématérialisation
permettrait de remplacer les
hommes et les femmes qui
accueillaient nos concitoyens dans
un grand nombre de services
publics.
Fort de ce constat et du sentiment
d'abandon, par un grand nombre de
nos concitoyens, et notamment en
milieu rural, le gouvernement a
mis en place un dispositif
d'accompagnement sur l'ensemble du
territoire au travers des maisons
France services.
Contrairement à ce que disent
certains dans le "vrai monde", la
situation s'améliore et de
nombreux Français peuvent avoir
accès à des services auxquels ils
ne pouvaient pas avoir accès
auparavant, que ce soit au travers
des maisons ou des bus France
services, ce sont des territoires
très éloignés qui disposent de
permanence et d'un accès aux
services publics.
Je sais que ce sujet vous tient
particulièrement à coeur.
C'est pourquoi je souhaiterais que
vous puissiez indiquer à la
représentation nationale que vous
et vos équipes continuent
inlassablement à travailler sur ce
sujet et que vous considérez que
votre objectif est toujours celui
de faire mieux.
Monsieur le ministre,
pourriez-vous nous préciser
quelles sont vos nouvelles
priorités pour continuer ce
travail de réconciliation entre
nos concitoyens et nos services
publics?
Quels sont vos objectifs, que vous
vous fixez, notamment pour étendre
et mieux faire connaître ce
dispositif?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Stanislas
Guerini, ministre de la
Transformation et de la Fonction
publiques.
- Stanislas Guerini: Merci.
Madame la députée, merci de
m'interroger sur un dispositif qui
ne fait pas tout le temps la une
de la presse nationale ou les
bandeaux des chaînes d'info en
continu, mais qui change la vie
des gens, et qui s'appelle France
services.
Je veux saluer votre
investissement remarquable sur ce
sujet, le travail que vous avez
mené avec un sénateur, vos
propositions.
Beaucoup ont été reprises.
J'étais il y a quelques jours à
Lannion pour inaugurer un espace
France services.
C'était important à deux titres.
C'était dans une sous-préfecture.
Suite au choix du président de la
République, nous investissons dans
les réseaux de sous-préfecture et
nous en réouvrons.
C'est très important de remettre
des services publics dans nos
sous-préfectures.
A Lannion, j'ai croisé des
concitoyens qui retrouvaient le
chemin d'une sous-préfecture, le
chemin de l'Etat sur le
territoire.
C'était la 2700e maisons France
services que nous avons
réouvertes.
Nous avons relevé la promesse du
président, ramener des services
publics à moins de 30 minutes de
chacun de nos concitoyens.
C'est désormais chose faite car
c'est désormais à moins de 20
minutes de chaque Français que se
trouve un espace France services.
Cela marche aussi car plus de 8
fois sur 10, quand quelqu'un s'y
rend, son sujet est traité
lorsqu'il en sort.
Les agents qui sont bien formés,
et je veux les saluer aujourd'hui,
nous allons continuer à investir
pour eux, dans leur niveau de
compétence.
Tous les acteurs du territoire le
font ensemble et nous allons
continuer à faire de même en
relevant le ticket de financement
de 30.000 à 50.000 euros pour
chacun des espaces.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
- Marie-Agnès Poussier-Winsback:
Merci, monsieur le ministre.
J'espère que nous pourrons aussi
envisager l'expérimentation avec
les communes rurales pour le
dernier kilomètre.
J'espère que nous pourrons
examiner cette possibilité.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur José
Gonzalez pour le Rassemblement
National.
- José Gonzalez: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Honorables collègues, une fois de
plus, votre gouvernement s'apprête
à trahir les classes moyennes
françaises, ces travailleurs et
retraités qui font tenir notre
pays debout.
Voilà 10 ans qu'Emmanuel Macron
accable les familles françaises de
taxes et d'impôts divers.
Nos compatriotes plébiscitaient
les mesures sur le pouvoir d'achat
proposées par Marine Le Pen, vous
avez fait diversion avec des
promesses que vous saviez
intenables.
Au printemps dernier, Emmanuel
Macron et Gabriel Attal ont promis
aux classes moyennes deux
milliards d'euros de baisses
d'impôts.
Les députés du Rassemblement
National avaient dénoncé ce
mensonge et nous avions raison.
Les médias étaient focalisés sur
l'immigration et les familles
françaises veulent couper avec
l'actualité pour profiter des
fêtes de fin d'année, mais les
macronistes ont annoncé en catimini
que cette baisse d'impôts n'aurait
pas lieu.
Les Français paieront la hausse
des taxes sur l'électricité de 300
à 500 euros par foyer.
Jamais les énergies n'ont jamais
coûté aussi chers.
Comment justifiez-vous un tel
cynisme?
Les députés du Rassemblement
National vont dénoncer cette
escroquerie fiscale.
Vous prétendez puiser dans les
poches des Français au nom des
finances publiques mais vous ne
faites aucune économie
structurelle, vous ne luttez
contre aucun gaspillage et vous ne
touchez à aucun privilège.
Vous avez payé des dizaines de
milliards des classes moyennes et
vous allez leur faire payer les
avantages des oligarques dans la
mondialisation.
Votre gouvernement va honorer une
seule promesse fiscale, celle de
créer un paradis fiscal pour les
organisations internationales.
Quand allez-vous cesser de prendre
l'argent des Français pour
financer votre débâcle budgétaire?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci, la
parole est à monsieur Thomas
Cazenave, ministre en charge des
Comptes publics.
- Thomas Cazenave: Monsieur le
député, nous ne vous avons pas
attendu pour baisser les impôts et
nous préoccuper du pouvoir d'achat
des Français.
Nous sommes la majorité qui avons
baissé de 50 milliards d'euros les
impôts depuis 2017.
25 milliards d'euros pour les
Français.
Baisse de la taxe d'habitation, de
la redevance audiovisuelle.
Dans le budget que nous avons
adopté, indexation du barème de
l'impôt sur le revenu, indexation
des prestations sociales et des
pensions de retraite pour 16
milliards d'euros.
Vous nous faites des procès sur la
débâcle budgétaire.
Je n'ai encore jamais entendu la
seule proposition d'économie
venant de vos bancs.
Nous redressons les finances
publiques.
Est-ce que vous pensez, quand on a
protégé les industries, les
entreprises...
85 milliards d'euros pour le
bouclier énergétique!
Voilà des mesures qui ont évité
l'effondrement de nos entreprises
et des ménages.
Il est temps de revenir en
arrière.
Pourquoi?
Pour réduire notre déficit public
et pour garantir notre
souveraineté.
Mais vous ne partagez pas ces
objectifs.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La prochaine question va être
posée par monsieur Hubert
Wulfranc.
Avant de lui donner la parole, je
voudrais qu'on lui rende
collectivement hommage.
Il va poser aujourd'hui sa
dernière question au gouvernement.
Applaudissements
Député de la 3e circonscription de
Seine-Maritime depuis 2017,
opposant opiniâtre mais toujours
courtois, vous avez également
exercé plusieurs mandats locaux,
notamment comme maire et
conseiller départemental.
Vous vous êtes ainsi investi avec
beaucoup de passion et de talent,
beaucoup d'engagement au service
des Français, et la représentation
nationale vous en est
particulièrement reconnaissante.
...
- Hubert Wulfranc: Madame la
présidente, mesdames et messieurs
les ministres, mon ultime
question, je la dois à un copain
d'enfance.
Je l'ai rencontré dans les manifs
sur les retraites.
En ce début d'année, il attendait
des résultats d'examens.
Le diagnostic est tombé, maladie
de Charcot.
En cette fin d'année, il est déjà
affecté physiquement.
Il s'avère que cette terrible
maladie fait l'objet d'une
actualité particulière, en lien
avec l'action de l'association
pour la recherche sur la sclérose
latérale amyotrophique.
Plusieurs ministres sur ces bancs
ont apporté ces dernières semaines
des éléments de réponse attendus
par l'association.
Mise en oeuvre d'un travail
d'identification des besoins pour
une meilleure prise en charge des
malades, coordination de santé
spécifique entre la médecine de
ville et l'hôpital, nouveaux
médicaments autorisés en accès
compassionnel dans notre pays.
L'enjeu crucial reste néanmoins la
recherche pour espérer enfin
sortir cette maladie des maladies
incurables.
Ma question est donc simple:
peut-on espérer que la maladie de
Charcot soit déclarée grande cause
nationale et que le plan maladies
rares dispose d'un engagement
financier sans précédent?
Merci de votre réponse.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup, mon cher collègue.
La parole...
La parole est à madame Agnès
Firmin Le Bodo, ministre de la
Santé et de la Prévention.
- Agnès Firmin Le Bodo: Monsieur
le député Hubert Wulfranc, tout
d'abord, vous dire toute l'émotion
qui est la mienne de répondre à
votre dernière question au
gouvernement.
Nous avons passé pas mal de temps
ensemble sur ces bancs et au
département de la Seine-Maritime,
et nous avons eu l'occasion de
traverser ensemble un moment
dramatique, qui est celui de
l'attentat de la commune où vous
étiez maire.
La France entend jouer un rôle
pionnier dans la prise en charge
des patients atteints de maladies
rares, à la fois pour soutenir la
recherche, améliorer la recherche
de la prise en charge des
personnes et mieux accompagner
leurs proches.
Un quatrième plan est en cours
d'élaboration.
Nous devons tenir compte des
retours d'expérience des
précédents plans, et des
réflexions sont menées pour
proposer des pistes
d'amélioration.
Pour favoriser la recherche des
traitements innovants, le plan
national a pour ambition de
favoriser les dialogues entre les
parties prenantes du secteur et
les industriels.
Le plan en 2025 va permettre
d'avancer les connaissances sur
cette pathologie et de développer
une thérapie ciblée.
Des ajustements sont apportés au
dispositif d'accès précoce et
d'accès compassionnel pour faire
progresser l'accès des patients
tout en améliorant leur sécurité
financière.
Nous voulons mieux accompagner les
patients au fur et à mesure de
l'évolution de leur maladie, tout
en leur assurant la meilleure
qualité de vie possible.
Je pense à l'amélioration des
parcours du patient entre la ville
et l'hôpital.
Le gouvernement partage votre
engagement.
Vous pouvez compter sur notre
détermination et je sais compter
sur l'engagement des
parlementaires.
Je vous souhaite bon vent et nous
savons qu'il souffle très fort en
Seine-Maritime.
Et un joyeux anniversaire à votre
voisin!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
Monsieur le député?
- Hubert Wulfranc: Je vous laisse
le soin de faire progresser ce
dossier important pour nos
concitoyens.
Applaudissements
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Inaki
Echaniz pour le groupe socialiste.
- Inaki Echaniz: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Madame la Première ministre, ce 19
décembre restera comme une date
sombre dans l'histoire de la
République.
Un projet de loi sur l'immigration
inspiré du programme historique de
l'extrême droite et de Jean-Marie
Le Pen a été adopté par le
Parlement grâce aux voix du
Rassemblement National.
Malgré vos éléments de langage,
les chiffres sont têtus.
C'est bien les 88 votes du
Rassemblement National qui vous
permettent d'obtenir une majorité
sur ce texte de la honte.
La minorité présidentielle avait
fixé des lignes rouges, elles ont
toute été allègrement
transgressées et ce sont désormais
les lignes bleues marine qui sont
tranchées.
Vous avez cédé sur tout, les
amendements, les articles et
surtout votre honneur.
Cette loi demeurera comme le
moment où le mandat Macron s'est
vautré dans le déshonneur.
En 2017, en 2022, nous avons uni
nos voix contre le Rassemblement
National pour faire élire Emmanuel
Macron.
Ce temps est désormais révolu.
Le gouvernement en est désormais
le porte-voix.
Le président du barrage
républicain est devenu celui du
naufrage républicain.
Ce texte a fracturé votre camp et
le contrat social qui fait notre
République.
J'ai honte pour vous, collègues
qui, comme moi, sont issus de
l'immigration, et qui ont mêlé
leur voix à l'extrême droite.
Vous avez permis l'adoption de ce
texte.
Si ce texte était en vigueur à
l'arrivée de vos ancêtres, vous ne
seriez pas ici.
Je pense aussi et surtout à nos
concitoyens, enfants d'étrangers,
qui ont bénéficié d'aides sociales
qui leur ont permis d'étudier
sereinement à l'école de la
République, à ceux qui ont pu
bénéficier automatiquement de la
nationalité française grâce au
droit du sol.
Pour tous ces gens, nous allons
dénoncer ce texte au Conseil
constitutionnel.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Eric
Dupond-Moretti, garde des Sceaux
et ministre de la Justice.
- Eric Dupond-Moretti: Merci.
Merci, madame la présidente.
Il régnait jusqu'à ce moment une
ambiance assez tranquille, et je
voudrais pouvoir...
Je voudrais pouvoir vous répondre.
La déchéance de nationalité, elle
est dans le Code civil, ce
monsieur François Hollande, sauf
erreur de ma part.
Deuxièmement, vous êtes tombé dans
le piège du Rassemblement
National, qui crie victoire.
Voyez-vous, une victoire en
réalité, c'est lorsqu'on a livré
un combat.
Je vais vous rappeler quelque
chose très simple.
Dans ce texte, le RN n'a pas
ajouté une ligne, et pas un mot.
Au Sénat, ils votent contre le
texte.
Devant la commission des lois de
l'Assemblée, ils votent contre le
texte!
En CMP, ils ne proposent rien.
A l'Assemblée, c'est avec vous
qu'ils votent.
Et avec personne d'autre.
Qu'est-ce que ça donne au final?
Ca donne que madame la présidente
Le Pen vote enfin le texte alors
que son Premier ministre
autoproclamé dit qu'il ne le
votera pas.
Première crise dans votre
gouvernement!
C'est un conte de Noël qui nous
est raconté.
A vaincre sans péril, on triomphe
sans gloire.
Ce n'est pas une victoire,
c'est la plus grande escroquerie
politique de l'année.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Karl
Olive pour le groupe Renaissance.
- Karl Olive: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
Olivier Dussopt, ministre du
Travail.
Monsieur le ministre, notre
premier combat est l'emploi.
L'an passé, nous avons fait le
pari du plein emploi pour 2027.
Cet objectif est inscrit dans
votre périmètre ministériel.
Cet objectif est partagé par de
nombreux acteurs économiques...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Attendons que
l'hémicycle fasse silence.
On n'entend rien.
Vous n'avez pas la parole.
Monsieur Karl Olive doit pouvoir
poser sa question.
Arrêtez de vous invectiver.
- Karl Olive: Notre premier
combat, c'est l'emploi.
L'an passé, nous avons fait le
pari du plein emploi pour 2027.
Cet objectif est inscrit dans
votre périmètre ministériel.
Cet objectif est partagé par de
nombreux acteurs économiques,
notamment par la filière
automobile.
Ce fleuron de l'industrie
française est aujourd'hui en plein
bouleversement lié entre autres à
l'électrification du parc
automobile et à la transition
écologique.
Il a fait le choix d'investir dans
nos territoires et de créer de
l'emploi en France et en Europe.
Je pense évidemment
aux gigafactories
dans le nord de la France.
Ce choix est confronté au défi de
la main-d'oeuvre et du
recrutement.
La filière investit à nos côtés
pour développer les cursus
professionnel, dans les campus
innovants comme à Poissy, campus
qui va ouvrir ses portes en 2024
et que nous avons visité ensemble
la semaine dernière.
Ce campus porte des solutions pour
rendre attractifs les emplois de
la filière automobile, en
développant pour lui 1500 salariés
et de nouvelles formes de travail.
Les avancées proposées sur le
terrain et les objectifs du plein
emploi vont-ils permettre de
réenchanter la filière
industrielle en France?
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Dussopt, ministre du Travail.
- Olivier Dussopt: Merci.
Monsieur le député, j'ai entendu
votre question et j'ai plaisir à
rappeler que nous étions ensemble
à Poissy la semaine dernière pour
accompagner la construction d'un
centre de formation pour former
aux métiers de demain.
C'est un outil essentiel à la
reconquête industrielle.
Nous conjuguons nos forces pour
accompagner le retour de
l'industrie sur notre territoire.
Au troisième trimestre 2023,
l'économie française a augmenté le
nombre d'emplois de 36.000, dont
12.000 dans le secteur industriel.
Le dialogue social doit faire que
les métiers soient plus
attractifs.
Nous devons faire des efforts dans
la formation pour répondre aux
tensions de recrutement.
Nous déployons des formation pour
accompagner la montée en
compétences des salariés pour leur
permettre d'acquérir les
compétences nécessaires aux
nouvelles technologies.
275 millions d'euros y seront
consacrés l'année prochaine.
Le plan France 2030 permet de
développer les emplois de demain.
Nous faisons en sorte que les
demandeurs aient accès à des
formations qualifiantes pour les
métiers de l'industrie.
Nous portons la volonté d'élargir
les critères d'accès à
l'éligibilité et au financement de
ces formations aux jeunes de moins
de 26 ans, et en levant toutes les
conditions de formation initiale
pour les allocataires du RSA, pour
les chômeurs senior, afin de
former un maximum de monde.
Nous avons une opportunité majeure
pour retrouver notre souveraineté
industrielle.
Il y a également l'enjeu de
permettre à l'industrie d'avoir
les ressources humaines et les
compétences nécessaires pour faire
face à tout ça.
Sans ces compétences, d'autres les
auront.
Nous accompagnons les groupes qui
investissent.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Sylvie
Ferrer pour la France Insoumise.
- Sylvie Ferrer: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de l'Agriculture.
En 2013, la France cessait toute
expérimentation d'OGM en plein
champ.
Elle faisait le choix d'appliquer
le principe de précaution, de ne
pas faire pousser n'importe quoi,
n'importe où.
Quand on joue à l'apprenti
sorcier, il vaut mieux être sûr de
son coup.
Aucune culture n'est étanche.
La pollinisation propage les gènes
des plantes de manière
incontrôlable.
Personne ne peut remettre le génie
de la nature dans sa lampe.
La Commission européenne a eu une
idée brillante, elle a cru qu'en
changeant les lettres, elle
résoudra le problème.
Elle ne parle plus d'OGM mais de
NTG, qui se heurtent à des
controverses scientifiques quant à
leur impact et au principe de
précaution.
Même enjeu mais plus aucune règle.
Les espaces modifiées ne seront
pas tracées et ne pourront pas
être révoquées.
On les retrouvera dans toutes les
cultures, bio ou non, et dans
toutes les assiettes sans aucune
conscience de leur impact.
C'est la marchandisation du vivant
par les multinationales
semencières.
Nos consommateurs méritent mieux,
notre environnement mérite mieux.
La Commission européenne ne peut
agir sans l'aval du gouvernement.
Monsieur le ministre, notre
agriculture et l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens, allez-vous laisser
l'Union Européenne ouvrir cette
boîte de Pandore?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Marc
Fesneau, ministre de
l'Agriculture.
- Marc Fesneau: Merci de cette
question qui me permet d'éclairer
les choses.
On ne gagne jamais à caricaturer.
Vous amalgamez les OGM avec les
NGT.
Les nouvelles techniques
génomiques, c'est de
l'intragenèse, c'est
l'accélération d'un processus qui
se passerait dans la nature.
On gagne des années précieuses.
Le gouvernement soutient cette
proposition car nous avons besoin
d'alternatives.
On ne peut pas lutter contre le
dérèglement climatique, réduire
les produits phytosanitaires, et
se priver de l'un des outils
prometteurs pour accompagner nos
agriculteurs.
La France a veillé à trois sujets.
Le premier a été acquis grâce à la
présidence espagnole, c'est qu'on
ne puisse pas utiliser cette
technique pour créer des variétés
résistantes aux herbicides.
Deuxième élément, nous distinguons
les catégories.
Troisièmement, nous faisons en
sorte qu'elles ne soient pas
utilisées.
Quatrième élément, on a besoin de
donner aux agriculteurs des
capacités à engager la transition
et à continuer à produire.
On a besoin d'avancer sur ces
sujets en conscience et avec la
science.
Ce que je dis, la science le dit.
- Sylvie Ferrer: Je vois pour qui
vous roulez, monsieur le ministre.
La France s'est positionnée pour
les NTG.
L'Allemagne s'est positionnée
contre.
Je constate que vous maintenez
votre position.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Sandrine Rousseau pour le
groupe écologiste.
- Sandrine Rousseau: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à madame la
secrétaire d'Etat en charge de
l'enfance.
Le déshonneur du gouvernement ne
s'arrête pas à la question
migratoire, la pause hivernale
arrive.
Je souhaitais vous poser la
question de la Ciivise.
La commission a été créée en 2021
après le livre de Camille
Kouchner.
30.000 personnes ont été
auditionnées en deux ans, 82
préconisations en sont sorties.
Vous avez annoncé le maintien de
la Ciivise en évinçant sa tête.
11 membres ont démissionné suite à
cette annonce.
Le choix des personnes nommées à
leur suite interroge.
L'affaire d'Outreau a été énoncée
par la personne qui va prendre la
tête de la Ciivise immédiatement
après sa prise de position.
Il y a un rapport genré aux
violences sexuelles.
Trois enfants par classe.
Le mot "inceste" étant un des mots
les plus recherchés sur les sites
pornographiques.
On ne sait pas combien il y a de
pédocriminels parce que nous
n'avons pas de statistiques.
Est-ce que c'est parce que le juge
pointait la faiblesse de vos
dispositions qu'il a été évincé?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Charlotte Caubel.
- Charlotte Caubel: Permettez-moi
de m'étonner du soupçon et du
mépris que j'entends dans votre
question à l'endroit du nouveau
président de la Ciivise, dont
l'engagement et l'expertise sont
unanimement reconnus, sinon
appréciés.
Remettez-moi d'en profiter pour
condamner les propos nauséabonds
que je vois circuler depuis
quelques jours au sujet d'un homme
et d'une femme qui ont accepté
cette mission au nom de la cause
qui nous anime tous, celle de la
protection des enfants, et qui
sont engagés dans cette mission
depuis de nombreuses années,
peut-être avant moi et vous.
Permettez-moi de penser que la
reconnaissance de la parole des
victimes, que l'engagement auprès
des victimes n'a pas de monopole.
Cette parole ne se réduit pas au
plébiscite apparent d'un homme, au
travail d'une ministre ou d'un
gouvernement.
C'est un combat qui doit être mené
par tout le monde et qui a été
mené largement par cette majorité.
Aucun gouvernement avant nous
n'avait utilisé le mot "inceste".
Sur les propositions, 41 ont déjà
été mise en place et 21 sont en
train d'être inspectées par une
commission.
J'ai dit que je rendrai compte des
préconisations de la Ciivise
devant la représentation
parlementaire.
Nous allons saluer le travail du
nouvel office des mineurs qui a
permis un coup de filet de 80
personnes interpellées.
Nous ne lâchons sur les
pédocriminalités.
On peut continuer à polémiquer
mais je souhaite tous mes voeux de
succès au nouveau président et à
la nouvelle vice-présidente.
11 personnes ont démissionné, et
neuf autres avaient déjà claqué la
porte compte tenu le
fonctionnement de la Ciivise.
Personne n'a le monopole de cet
engagement.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Madame
Sandrine Rousseau?
- Sandrine Rousseau: Les
condamnations pour pédocriminalité
ont diminué alors que les plaintes
ont augmenté.
Il faut une réforme et des moyens.
Il faut une volonté politique.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La séance est terminée.
La séance est suspendue.